[Music]
we are partnering with digital media
company refinery29 for our new series
called my generation refinery29 is
dedicated to issues affecting millennial
women this morning we explore the often
overlooked 67 percent that is the 67% of
women in America who refinery29 says are
considered plus-sized 14 and up despite
being a significant majority of the
population plus-size women only make up
a reported 1 to 2 percent of what we see
in the media refinery29
is working to change that imbalance I
grew up reading magazines and really
using them as my personal Bible there
was never really anybody on TV that I
could personally relate to the plus-size
girl was always the funny friend and
never the main character the only
representation I ever saw of my size was
Ursula from The Little Mermaid so a
villain if I can't be defined then am I
even like worth anything if there's no
definition of Who I am
and the standard is not even your own
personal standard it's the standard that
other people gives you so where does
that leave us as plus women
and with us this morning refinery29
co-founder and executive creative
director peerage allari gelati also
history-making model Denise fado she's
the first plus-size model to walk on
multiple straight sized runways at New
York Fashion Week P era Denise great to
have you thanks for coming on so we're
not I guess what was the turning point
to finally make you focus on the 60%
seven percent of the population so
refinery29 as a platform that's really
meant to celebrate and empower all women
and we've always been really focused on
representation to the extent that I
actually used to go out and cast models
on the subway and the streets of New
York so that we could be really
representing what real women look like
and last year we learned that 67% of
women in the US are size 14 and up and
yet media only represents them one to
two percent and when we did an audit of
ourselves even though we had been really
focused on showing real women we
realized that we had fallen short and
for us it was so important to to fill
that you know that space and to
celebrate plus-sized women and do better
by the plus-size community what's the
response been from readers that's far
you know we get so many really moving
letters from women saying thank you I've
never seen myself represented in in
media before I grew up not seeing
someone that looked like me and just
really a lot of appreciation for being
being seen and being recognized Denise
can you see it happening in front of
your eyes today the changing perception
absolutely I mean I started modeling
about ten years ago and what I find so
remarkable is that I've been able to not
only be a driving force behind this
change that we're now starting to see
but also to be able to mold the next
generation because now what they're zine
is so different from what we grew up
with we're creating empowering strong
opinionated and confident women little
girls walking around so I can't wait to
see what that does to them what did it
mean to you I love how you got me so
they say you made history walking in
this straight sighs what did it mean to
you to do that number one what did that
feel like n you wrote a very moving
essay in refinery
twenty-nine about your own mother
struggle you wanted to tell that story
but first what it meant for you and then
what effect it's having on your mom and
now you have a daughter right
in 2014 I got the honor to open the crow
Metro at New York Fashion Week which was
something I was told many times would
never even be possible but to get to
open that one and then walk the Serena
Williams show and closed that one was
such a huge milestone for our industry
and our possibilities and opportunities
and I think that was the first moment
that people really saw us and we're like
oh my god
why wouldn't they walk alongside
alongside regular models why would we
exclude them we should just have a
lineup of fully diverse individual women
who can rock the clothes because that's
the goal is for us to be able to look at
the runways to look at the billboards to
look at these ads and see ourselves and
know that we can rock that cool clothing
as well but there is pushback guys and I
know you've heard it from people say but
you're promoting unhealthy life you're
you're promoting unhealthy body types
you're promoting obesity that this is
not a good thing to promote and to that
you say what well we we definitely hear
that feedback from people and to me that
really underscores a bias that we have
in our society you know Beyonce said
perfection is a disease of a nation it's
the soul that needs a surgery and I
think that's really true that bias is
really held very deep in our country and
what's happening is by really focusing
on this standard of beauty that promotes
thinness we leave so many women out and
we really perpetuate shame and I don't
think that shame is a motivator for
healthy behavior I think we're talking
about health but what about mental
health and this self-love that you need
to be confident and exist in the world
and heal yourself right I think the
moment that women can see themselves in
the media and in these features
alongside everyone and we have these
diverse campaigns what we create is this
internal happiness that starts to seep
out and I think when we create this
generation of women who are supporting
each other and who are happy we change
the playing field eliminates bias and we
start casting them in the leading role
right yeah that support exactly I like
that word that phrase Denise internal
happiness
bit of that single-dose yeah thank you
both for coming today